when aegon finally saw the monstrous
castle he asked for pali
haren granted it
valeria had been the greatest empire the
world had ever seen
aaron wanted to piss on its ashes
yield now and you may remain as lord of
the iron islands
yield now
and your sons will live to rule after
you
you see my army outside your walls you
see my dragons
what is outside my walls is of no
concern those walls are strong and thick
dragons fly
but stone doesn't burn
when the sun sets
your line shall end
aaron spat and returned to his castle
once inside he promised lands riches and
tally's daughters to whoever could bring
down aegon or his dragon
as the sun sank below the horizon all of
heron's men patrolled the battlements
hearing wings in every gust of wind
but the moon rose and sank
and no dragon appeared
while the ironborn were ringing the
battlements aegon drove his dragon
balerion higher and higher in the night
sky so that even the great castle of
herren hall looked like an ant hill
below them
then they plunged straight into the
castle well inside the guarded walls
the five towers of heron hall reached
towards aegon like a hand
valerion opened his mouth and bathed all
the fingers in flame
harren was right
stone doesn't burn
but men do
even when they're ironborn
the dragon blasted my ancestors into ash
that choked the survivors when they
screamed
harren soldiers leapt from the
battlements and died
they huddled against the walls and died
they fled across the yard and died
aaron and his sons took shelter inside
the castle
stone didn't burn
but as valerian blasted it with fire it
blowed white hot
the world's greatest castle became the
world's greatest oven
baking the last of thousara within it
outside the castle walls the towers of
herren hall glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five
huge candles with liquid stone trickling
down their sides like wax
the next morning aegon forged a new
riverlands
he named the rebel edmund tully as his
lord paramount of the trident and had
the other riverlords swear him fealty as
their new liege
for centuries house horror had
terrorized the riverlands
under house tully the riverlands would
at last return to peace and prosperity
after the castle cooled enough to allow
men inside aegon ventured into the ruin
he'd made of hair and hall
he saw the ashen bodies the scorched
stone and the mangled and melted swords
of his former enemies
to his men's confusion he ordered these
useless swords collected and sent to his
aegon fort
when aegon and his dragons burned haron
the black and all his sons at harrenhal
the days when men feared the sight of
our long ships were over aegon would not
permit marauders and raiders in his
seven kingdoms
with harren died our empire and the old
way that forged it
but what is dead may never die
six years after robert wrathion won his
crown my father balon greyjoy sought to
restore our ancient rights
he declared the iron islands independent
and himself its king and sent the iron
fleet in a daring raid on lannisport
where they burned the lannister ships at
anchor
making us unchallenged in the sunset sea
this was the seed of our undoing
my eldest brother roderick led a frontal
assault on seaguard a town built to
protect the mainland from us after
ferocious fighting beneath the city
walls he was slain by lord jason
mallister and his men defeated
by this time stannis baratheon had
brought robert's fleet around westeros
and somehow managed to trap the iron
fleet at fair isle smashing it
robert's victory was now over to shored
yet we made him bleed for each island
stannis baratheon captured great wick
the largest of the iron islands and said
barristan selmy himself subdued old wick
robert and lord eddard stark led the
main assault against the island of pike
they raised the town of lordsport to the
ground before robert turned his full
fury on our family's stronghold
when they breached the walls the first
threw was thoros of mir with his
ridiculous flaming sword
followed by every minor lord of westeros
hungry for glory
my other brother maron was killed when
the siege engines brought down a tower
on his head
i was now my father's only living son
an heir to the iron islands
when my father saw his cause was lost he
wisely conceded defeat to robert who
otherwise would have pulled down our
castle stone by stone with us in it
as my father said to me then
no man has ever died from bending his
knee
he who kneels may rise again blade in
hand
he who will not kneel stays dead
stiff legs and all
as it stands robert allowed my father to
keep his lands and title as lord of the
iron islands king of salt and rock son
of the sea wind lord reaper of pike
for a price
his last son and air shipped off to
winterfell as an honored guest
i would eat at the stark's table and
play with the stark children
and if my father rebelled again
stark would take his sword and cut off
my head
it would be his duty
though robert had risked all our lives
to win it the iron throne bored him he
cared little for justice and less for
rule
if it weren't women or wine skinny had
no use for it
without the stalwart john aaron as hand
of the king the challenge to robert's
crown would have come much earlier than
it did
the iron islands have never lacked for
treachery
they respect only strength
and honor
is as foreign to them as the seven
after six years their ruler
lord balon greyjoy wagered that king
robert had not won the support of the
great houses of westeros
many of whom still named him usurper
lord balon declared the iron islands
independent
and sent his iron fleet to lannisport
lord tywin lannister was careless
and the ironborn caught and burnt his
ships at anchor
lord balon and his reavers controlled
the sunset sea robert then ordered me to
succeed where his father-in-law lord
tywin had failed
beneath robert's fury i sensed relief
war he could understand
he would smash lord balon as he had
rhaegar
i raised robert's fleet and sailed
around westeros to the iron islands
i set a trap for the iron fleet off fair
isle
as sailors and warriors the ironborn are
unparalleled
but they're not soldiers
they have no discipline no strategy no
unity
in a battle each man fights only for his
own glory and their longships are built
for lightning strikes and shore raids
when the captains rushed in
i smashed their longships with our
larger war galleys
the strength of the ironborn is in their
ships with the iron fleet broken
i had assured robert's victory
he could now transport troops and siege
weapons to invade the iron islands
and contrary to balon's hopes robert had
plenty of both
i've never seen such allegiance as
robert could inspire in war
enemies who tried to kill him one day
would be drinking within the next under
their own fallen banners
in rebelling against the iron throne
lord balon did more than robert ever
could to cement his rule
when robert came to the iron islands he
brought with him the full power of
westeros
sir barristan selmy of the king's guard
led the assault on old wick while i
subdued great wick the largest of the
iron islands but robert saved the seat
of house greyjoy
pike for himself and lord eddard
robert would later boast of the battle's
bloodiness and how he could have torn
down the island into the waves if lord
balon hadn't bent the knee
but if i'd have led the assault
baylon's neck would have bent
under his sword
because i do not forget
i do not pardon
his time will come
all their times will come
the seven are gods of weakness and
defeat pretty chains that the first men
kindly put on after the andals crushed
them
except in the iron islands
since the dawn age the ironborn have
followed the drowned god
who plucked fire from the sea
and made us to reeve and sack and carve
our names in blood and song
when the andals landed on the iron
islands they found a god who was father
warrior and stranger
who took mother maiden and crone when he
would and held the smith enthrall
his priests are the drowned men who are
clothed and armed by the sea itself
they consecrate us to the drowned god
through our most sacred right
the drowning
and ask the god to raise us from the sea
as he was
harder and stronger
the ironborn do not fear the bloodiest
battles or the roughest waves
for the drowned god taught us long ago
that what is dead may never die
when an ironborn falls we say the
drowned god needed a strong oarsman and
took him below to feast in the gods
watery halls attended by mermaids
but even in death an ironborn is a
warrior
we fight against the storm god who holds
a castle in the clouds and sends the
winds to lure the ironborn of course or
wreck our ships
it's said my legendary ancestor the grey
king waged war upon the storm god for a
thousand years with the drowned god's
help he slew the great sea dragon nagar
and used her bones for his hall
after his death the storm god tried to
wash away any memory of this terrible
foe
but his songs fill our halls to this day
it was the storm god who first blew the
andals to the iron islands to subdue us
and turn us from our faith
true they conquered and killed our king
but in time they forsook their septs for
the shore
and their fat septons for the drowned
men
the andals came to us as conquerors
in the end
they drowned
the ironborn of the sea
as our god made us
and given to it as our god taught us
we do not fear the storm god's winds or
his waves
but you should
for they bring us to you